bonjour à tous le peuple britannique a
choisi de quitter l'union européenne ce
choix doit être respecté il exprima
roger forts de l'europe telle qu'elle
fonctionne la lucidité commande de dire
que ce sentiment de rejet et partagé par
beaucoup de français et par beaucoup
d'autres européens
ce qu'a dit le peuple britannique
d'autres peuples en europe aurait pu le
dire nous ne pouvons ni nous devons
l'ignorer l'europe fonctionner sans les
britanniques et nous ayons d'ailleurs du
temps pour repenser nos relations avec
notre voisin en revanche l'europe
désormais à 27 ne peut plus fonctionner
de cette manière la question de sa
refondation profonde est donc urgente
elle n'a que trop tardé
je demande qu'une réunion de chefs
d'état et de gouvernement européens
prennent la décision d'élaborer un
nouveau traité qui montrera aux peuples
de notre continent que l'europe est
décidé à reprendre son destin en main
cinq piliers devrait organiser ce
nouveau traité premièrement le repas des
frontières il faut les faire respecter
et c'est dans cet esprit que nous devons
nous doter d'un gouvernement des
ministres de l'intérieur qui mettra en
oeuvre un schengen 2 la libre
circulation des européens en europe ne
signifie en aucun cas que les non
européens peuvent entrer et circuler
librement sur notre continent
deuxièmement il faut un gouvernement
économique de la zone euro avec un
président stable
élu par ses pairs il faut un fonds
monétaire européen qui assurera
l'indépendance
l'europe qui n'a nul besoin du fmi' pour
traiter de ses affaires internes
l'europe doit se comporter comme une
puissance et non comme un vassal
troisièmement le principe de
subsidiarité doit devenir enfin une
réalité les compétences européennes
doivent être regroupés autour d'une
petite dizaine de priorités stratégiques
comme l'agriculture l'énergie la
concurrence la politique commerciale la
recherche tout le reste toutes les
autres compétences devront être renvoyés
sans délai à la souveraineté des états
membres
quatrièmement la commission ne peut plus
cumuler des compétences exécutive
législative et judiciaire
elle doit mettre en oeuvre les décisions
du conseil européen plus aucun acte
délégués ou d'exécution ne doit pouvoir
être pris sans l'accord préalable du
parlement européen où des parlements
nationaux
nous ne voulons plus d'une europe
technocratique la démocratie a ses
règles
l'administration européenne doit s'y
conformer
cinquièmement le processus
d'élargissement de l'europe doit
clairement être stoppée jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
s'agissant de la turquie l'hypocrisie
doit laisser la place à la franchise qui
nous commande de dire les choses
clairement
c'est à dire que la turquie n'a pas sa
place dans l'union européenne
par ailleurs je demande qu'on revienne
sur la décision irresponsable de lever
les visas dans la situation sécuritaire
qui est la nôtre
la crise que nous vivons est majeur le
message des britanniques éclate à la
face de tous les gouvernements d'europe
il serait irresponsable de ne pas en
tenir compte
jamais je crois en l'europe plus que
jamais j'entends défendre l'idéal
européen
mais cet idéal je le veux avec les
peuples d'europe pas contre eux il y à
une civilisation européenne il y a une
identité européenne
il y a une culture européenne un mode de
vie européen qui repose sur les nations
ce sont d'abord les nations qui sont
notre force que les dirigeants européens
sache se montrer à la hauteur de
l'histoire qui ne leur pardonnera aucune
lâcheté
l'heure est donc à la lucidité à
l'énergie et au leadership
je vous remercie